le dos du jour on va parler de
l'inflation qui touche de plein fouet la
France depuis nombreux mois ce matin
j'ai eu un pote au téléphone il me
disait il y a de plus en plus de
personnes travaillent chez moi qui me
disent on aimerait avoir des avances le
10 le 11 le 12 et parce qu'ils me disent
et ben on fait exactement la même chose
qu'avant sauf qu'on se rend pas compte
ça nous coûte beaucoup plus cher et en
fait sur le moment on se rend pas compte
et le 10 du mois on commence à se dire
et ben ouais on a fait la même chose que
les autres mois mais maintenant ça nous
coûte beaucoup plus cher on tient plus
on aura Olivier d'Auverse journaliste et
spécialiste de la grande distribution
qui va nous donner des conseils pour
vous en sortir et surtout qui va nous
faire un point sur cette flambée des
prix qui fait vraiment de plus en plus
flipper regardez que ce soit la pompe ou
au caisse des supermarchés les prix
continuent de flamber et l'inflation
mais toujours à mal les Français quand
ils arrivent au moment de payer bien
souvent ben ils se rendent compte que il
y a plus assez ils ne prenne pour des
citrons et en eau presse et on nous
presse et on accepte tous et on cette
période de crise un mot vient de
resurgir dans notre vocabulaire la
shrinification absolument derrière ce
terme se cache une astuce des
industriels qui consiste à diminuer la
quantité de leurs produits tout en
gardant le même prix une astuce que nous
gouvernement voit d'un mauvais œil il
n'y a pas d'arnaque il n'y a pas
d'arnaque sur ces sujets sur ce produit
là alors comment faire face à la hausse
des prix shrink flexion alimentation
carburant tous les conseils pour
survivre à l'inflation ce soir dans TPMP
allez on va parler de l'inflation bien
sûr ce sujet qui touche tous les
Français et qui vraiment inquiétent
énormément de monde on a la chance
d'avoir crocodile
c'est du python
merci beaucoup crocodile alors on en est
où l'inflation
sérieuse on est sur le haut du col je
vais vous prendre une image en étant en
escalader le tournage ou l'Alpe d'Huez
vous appeler ça comme vous voulez et ça
fait deux ans qu'on a monté monté depuis
deux à trois mois je parle
d'alimentation on est sur le plateau
voire même du bon côté de la vallée ça
fait exactement un mois qu'on commence à
voir hein non mais factuellement si
ensuite on n'avait pas le ressenti ça je
peux l'entendre parce que parce que la
baisse elle est très très faible très
très faible mais quand vous êtes encore
une fois au sommet de l'Alpe d'Huez
quand vous commencez à aller du bon côté
dans la descente vous sortez pas tout de
suite et ben vous êtes encore très haut
et ben c'est exactement ça c'est à dire
oui on est du bon côté mais on est
toujours très haut et ce qui sont dans
la difficulté eux on a beau leur
expliquer que ça baisse il voit d'abord
connaît très haut et ils ont raison et
ils ont raison alors c'est quoi on parle
aujourd'hui beaucoup de shrink flation
alors la shrinflation c'est un phénomène
qui prend son nom déjà du mot anglais
qui s'appelle to swing je voulais dire
rétrécir bah c'est en gros je prends un
produit qui faisait un litre et demi il
fait désormais plus qu'un lit de 25 je
prends un produit qui faisait 600 g il
fait 500 €. donc au même prix là c'est
l'inflation plus cher c'est l'inflation
voilà c'est de l'inflation masquée et
donc c'est en gros j'en mets moins dans
le paquet que ce que je faisais avant
pareil
merci ma très très merci et donc ça
consiste pour les industriels à
dissimuler les hausses des prix comme il
a dit voilà en baissant la quantité
forcément de même qui vendent de
l'alcool qui baisse le taux d'alcool
pour le moment au même prix baisse le
taux d'alcool il y a une certaine marque
qui a été refusée de certaines enseignes
parce que selon les avaient baissé le
taux d'alcool de l'alcool qui était une
explication technique c'est que comme la
majorité du prix d'un alcool c'est des
taxes en fait c'est pour passer sous un
niveau de taxe puisque en gros quand
vous franchissez un seuil de taxe même
de degrés d'alcool pardon même à 0,1
degré près vous changez de taxe et donc
ça coûte beaucoup moins cher donc là
c'est pour qui est moins d'argent dans
la caisse de l'étang donc
arnaque dans tous les cas c'est légal
mais c'est pas moral parce qu'en fait
c'est ça le truc c'est que tant qu'on
dit au consommateur ce qu'il y a dans le
paquet qu'il achète ou dans la bouteille
qui l'achète on lui a pas menti s'il n'a
pas regardé c'est son problème plutôt
que celui de la marque donc d'un point
de vue légal il y a pas de problème
c'est pour ça que quand Bruno Le Maire
dit chevalier blanc de la shrinflation
il va monter sur son grand cheval et qui
va interdire ça il va falloir qu'il
explique comment parce que dès lors que
c'est affiché clairement le poids ou le
volume bon mais c'est pas moral pour
autant j'ai pas dit que c'était bien
Daniel vous qui voulez toujours savoir
ce qu'il y a dans le passé et dans
certains dans certains magasins il y a
les patrons pointe du doigt et mettent
une petite c'est le bal des hypocrites
c'est le bal des hypocrites parce qu'en
fait non oui bien sûr sauf que eux le
font aussi c'est pour ça que je vous dis
que c'est le bal des hypocrites si les
enseignes si les distributeurs étaient
clean sur ce procédé là à la limite on
pourrait se dire ils le font sincèrement
tous l'ont fait pour leur marque de
distributeur je vous prends un exemple
quand vous achetez des jus de fruits au
rayon frais désormais ils font tous 90
cl marque de distributeur y compris
pourquoi parce que innocent qui est la
grande marque est Tropicana a fait
pareil son passé sur un standard de
marché qui était un litre à 90
centilitres les mardes distributeur on
fait pareil donc ce sont quand même des
hypocrites c'est légal encore une fois
il y a pas de problème à moral mais que
ils prennent la tête de ce combat là
franchement moi qui suis ça matin midi
et soir ça m'a fait un peu marrer alors
moi il y a un autre question que je vais
vous poser à 20h37 qui a beaucoup de
gens qui nous rejoignent parmi les
choses qui posent problème il y a le
prix des carburants moi j'ai rien
compris à ce qu'ils ont fait là
qu'est-ce qu'ils veulent là en fait ils
disent ils envisagent l'autoriser la
vente à perdre des carburants ce qui est
ce qui est jusqu'ici illégal depuis 1963
c'est quoi l'histoire en général alors
l'idée c'est un coup politique c'est en
gros Elisabeth borne qui veut voir les
prix des carburants baissés parce que
elle sent bien que le niveau de tension
sociale on va comme ça dans le pays est
en train de monter monter monter et que
le carburant c'est très inflammable sans
mauvais jeu de mots non mais non mais
parce que c'est non mais les gilets
jaunes sont partis les carburants donc
c'est vraiment très sérieux et donc elle
s'est dit j'ai pas les moyens de baisser
les taxes en tous les cas le
pense-t-elle voilà ben je vais
transférer la responsabilité de la
baisse des prix et donc du déficit à des
acteurs privés en leur disant mais
écoutez les gars vous avez qu'à perdre
de l'argent Olivier Véran a quand même
dit 50 centimes par litre ce qui veut
quand même dire qu'en fac de médecine il
n'y a pas de cours déco parce que un mec
capable de vous dire on va baisser le
prix de 50 centimes et c'est des acteurs
privés qui vont le financer
il a dit il a dit 47 centimes pour être
précis oui il a dit ça il a dit ça ça a
été repris dans une dépêche AFP donc oui
il l'a dit mais c'est c'est un
finançable c'est c'était pas possible et
d'ailleurs ça ne se fera pas ils ont
tous refusé donc tout le monde a refusé
donc total énergie Carrefour Leclerc
Intermarché Système U tout le monde a
refusé et déjà annoncé qu'ils ne
vendraient pas de carburant à perte mais
ça n'existe pas une entreprise qui se
lève le matin des salariés qui se lèvent
en disant je
vais travailler et puis pourquoi pas un
coup de trompette pour dire qu'on est
content
donc là c'est quoi statu quo bah là ça
veut dire qu'au mieux il faut s'attendre
à des opérations à prix coûtant que les
enseignes font déjà mais c'est pas
possible d'imaginer que la baisse des
carburants se fasse par le financement
d'acteurs privés sur leur déficit
pourquoi ils baissent pas les taxes mais
voilà on peut pas baisser les taxes mais
pourquoi on peut pas les les je ne
représente pas Elisabelle borly je me
suis mis juste dans sa tête une seconde
comme elle ne veut pas elle ne veut pas
creuser le déficit je pense qu'il y a
des jeux politiques Bruno Le Maire qui
veut s'afficher comme un mec qui sait
tenir les cordons de la bourse parce
qu'il y a quand même 2027 en ligne de
mire il veut pas être celui qui ouvre à
volo et donc voilà donc c'est ça mais je
suis pas analyste politique
alors j'ai une autre j'ai un autre truc
il manque 600 euros français pour vivre
confortablement c'est un record chaque
année depuis 12 ans il y a le baromètre
Cofidis du pouvoir d'achat qui pose la
même question en français combien vous
manque-t-il chaque mois pour vivre
confortablement cette année les Français
estiment qu'il leur manque 588 euros par
mois c'est un record
ça dépassait pas les 500 euros c'est un
truc de fou comment ça se fait qu'est-ce
qui se passe alors il y a deux raisons
il y a une raison objective qui est
qu'effectivement la France est pas un
pays qui s'enrichit et les Français en
tous les cas pour une partie d'entre eux
sont quand même dans une difficulté
objective avérée et puis vous avez un
deuxième phénomène qu'il faut pas
occulter c'est qu'il y a un écart qui va
croissant chez nous tous entre notre
pouvoir d'achat et notre vouloir d'achat
c'est à dire on en veut tous plus que ce
qu'on ne le peut et donc entre les deux
se crée un écart qui s'appelle de la
frustration et cet écart il ne cesse
d'aller croissant et donc c'est
finalement c'est normal que dans ce
genre d'études chaque année on considère
qui nous en manque toujours plus parce
que chacun a son niveau de vie rêvé ben
moi il me faut et l'iPhone 15 et une
décapotable ça m'intéresse pas du tout
mais c'est pour vous illustrer le truc
et allez en vacances au soleil l'été et
à la montagne l'hiver etc etc et puis et
puis regardez ce que je mets dans les
vestes
moi j'ai surtout l'impression qu'il y a
des gens
il faut voir vivre et non plus survivre
mais il y a les deux c'est pour ça que
je vous ai dit les deux il y a ce
premier phénomène oui il y a des gens
qui sont dans la mouise de plus en plus
bien sûr je vois est-ce qu'on voit et
c'est ce que je dis à chaque fois je le
dis pratiquement tous les soirs
au lieu d'aider ceux qui font rien aider
les gens qui travaillent et qui s'en
sortent pas je suis désolé j'ai regardé
c'est certainement pas d'accord avec moi
c'est vrai voilà aujourd'hui il y a il y
a de plus le problème qu'on a
aujourd'hui c'est qu'on voit de plus en
plus de gens qui vous disent je
travaille ma femme travaille on s'en
sort pas on travaille de 9h à 19h tous
les jours et parfois on voit des mecs
comme on a vu hier l'influenceur qui dit
moi je prends 4000 euros par mois
qu'avec des aides donc à un moment il
faut moi moi le premier truc à faire
vous savez quand on a une radio
premier truc qu'on dit un directeur
d'antenne c'est va vérifier toutes les
émetteurs et bah quand on est ministre
de l'Économie première chose à vérifier
pour moi c'est où va où vont les aides
parce que il y a l'argent il va on aide
des gens qui font parfois qui profitent
du système et je pense qu'ils ça c'est
une manne financière énorme on aimerait
prendre cet argent pour le donner à des
gens qui travaillent et qui s'en sortent
pas et c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui je vous
dis on a vu la flambée des prix la
baguette a plus 10% le beurre c'est le
beurre qui a le plus augmenté avec les
légumes frais 23% des légumes frais 30%
d'augmentation comment vous faites quand
vous faites le même panier de course et
qu'à la fin et ben il vous coûte 30 % de
plus à et ben forcément 30% de plus ça
veut dire que tu as 10 jours dans le
mois ou tu es dans la merde et ben voilà
au lieu d'être allé jusqu'au 30 tu vas
jusqu'au 20 c'est ça franchement des
Français qui disent qu'ils font pas
trois repas par jour bien sûr mais c'est
pour ça que je vous ai dit que là la
première explication c'est qu'il y a une
masse objective de consommateur de
Français qui sont dans la difficulté je
n'ai pas contesté ça du tout je aussi
que en parallèle et on est tous
là-dedans on en veut tous plus qu'on ne
le peut c'est pas je dis pas que c'est
mal d'avoir des rêves c'est pas ça le
sujet il faut quand même qu'on s'auto
analyse aussi là-dessus on en veut tous
plus et c'est peut-être saint d'ailleurs
de rêver Delphine et d'ailleurs c'est
français là dont vous parlez la deuxième
catégorie il y a trois questions à se
poser je sais plus d'où ça vient mais
voilà quand on est devant quelque chose
qu'on a envie d'acheter on se pose la
question est-ce que j'en ai besoin
est-ce que j'en ai vraiment besoin et
est-ce que j'en ai vraiment besoin là
tout de suite c'est ça les trois
questions non oui et puis à un moment
donné il y a une qui arrive c'est est-ce
que je le peux et dès lors que vous
dites NON et ben vous vous sentez entre
guillemets pauvre en tous les cas dans
une approche sociologique parce que vous
avez dû renoncer à un achat pour une
raison pécuniaire et donc abrite à la
vie est du effectivement si vous devez
renoncer un truc que vous désirez c'est
dur à accepter et donc c'est là où il y
a de la frustration c'est pour ça que je
voudrais moi j'utilisais ce mot
frustration la consommation aujourd'hui
c'est de la frustration ce soir je vais
manger avec Daniel bon il y a une
question que tu dois pas te poser c'est
est-ce que je le veux
est-ce que je le veux vraiment est-ce
que je le veux vraiment
le quatrième
sur le principe elle peut mais dans les
faits ça sera contournable dans
l'instant je vous prendre un exemple
concret admettons que je fasse des
pommes rissolées surgelés elle faisait
600 grammes je les passe à 590 g je
trouve que c'est un carré bon voilà ou à
500 grammes peu importe et donc
Elisabeth borne va dire on va faire une
loi pour interdire ça ou alors pour
objet le fournisseur à dire attention à
mes consommateurs je suis en train de
vous je caricature un peu pour
qu'on comprenne bien le truc mais
qu'est-ce qui va se passer il va il va
pas faire des pommes rissolées surgelées
en 580 g il va alors il va changer de
nom il va les appeler pomme rissolées de
Picardie en 590 grammes et ça sera un
nouveau produit donc je veux dire c'est
hyper contournable parce que il y a
Bruno Le Maire aussi le ministre de
l'économie qui lui a affirmé combattre
la fameuse shrinkflation et annonce
qu'il sanctionnera les industriels qui
en feront l'usage donc tous autant qui
sont ils ont juste une ils ne disent que
ce qu'on a envie d'entendre nous les
consommateurs mais ça en oubliant
toujours que il y a un principe de
réalité sur les carburants c'était très
plais ce week-end et les automobilistes
d'entendre que on a les casser le prix
du carburant il y a aucun Français qui
était contre non voilà oui mais sauf que
quand on analyse un peu froidement
c'était pas possible bon ben c'est un
effet boomerang parce que politiquement
ça va coûter cher alors il y a le
gouverneur de la Banque de France c'est
qui c'est le gouvernement pour les
téléspectateurs c'est celui qui alors
qui gère une partie de la politique
monétaire française puisque comme on est
dans l'Europe et avec l'euro mais en
gros c'est le gardien du temple
financier on va l'appeler comme ça
personnage très important l'économise le
gouverneur de la Banque de France il a
dit il annonce objectif 2025 pour
l'inflation oui parce que
pour qu'on sorte de l'inflation sachant
qu'on est même pas certain qu'on en
sortira de manière vraiment réelle à
brève échéance parce que on rentre dans
ce qu'on appelle la transition
énergétique le changement de monde et ça
va coûter plus cher ça veut dire que
produire des produits propres va coûter
plus cher la question sera de savoir si
les Français sont capables de les
acheter et ça aujourd'hui avec le niveau
de pouvoir d'achat c'est pas gagné mais
donc on est même pas sûr qu'on en sorte
alors donc quoi c'est objectif 2025 mais
c'est pas sûr du tout je fais on peut
dire n'importe quoi là on peut dire
voilà ça va ce qui est ce qui est sûr
parce qu'aujourd'hui ce sont des faits
c'est que on est je vous l'ai dit pour
démarrer du bon côté du versant ça
commence à baisser alors mais c'est
tellement peu que personne s'en rend
compte et puis comme en parallèle vous
avez encore des produits qui montent
parce que ponctuellement vous avez des
crises sur l'huile d'olive qui est très
inflationniste sur le sucre voilà alors
que le blé à l'inverse est très
déflationniste aujourd'hui mais bon donc
on est dans ce qu'on appelle dans
l'épaisseur du trait ça ne se voit pas
malheureusement et pour que ça se voit
il va falloir attendre encore quelques
semaines alors ça veut dire pardon que
ça peut pas être pire que ce qu'on a
actuellement
ça ne peut pas être pire ça c'est sûr
parce que ça dépend de certains matières
premières est objectivement plus bas
c'est l'actualité aussi
si Poutine envahit encore plus Ukraine
et coupe le robinet à céréales ça fera
remonter le cours des céréales mais
malgré tout voilà mais malgré tout à
horizon visible on voit bien qu'on est
plutôt encore une fois du bon côté du
col je reprends ma métaphore parce que
c'est ça l'idée pour qu'on comprenne
bien que on peut être du bon côté du col
mais toujours très haut c'est ça voilà
alors aujourd'hui quelques chiffres pour
ceux qui n'ont jamais à 20h48 57 % des
Français puissent dans leur Espagne
épargne plus d'un Français sur de nous
l'abîment et les loisirs font partie des
postes de dépens sur lesquels les
Français prévoient de faire leur
économie 34% des Français ont baissé le
chauffage oui parce qu'en gros il y a
une forme de de ligne de partage ou de
clivage entre ce qui est essentiel et ce
qui les moins je vais vous l'illustrer
au travers de deux trois chiffres en
grande distribution aujourd'hui les
volumes c'est-à-dire le nombre
d'articles achetés est en train de
baisser d'à peu près 5% à peu près
retenez ce chiffre derrière cette
moyenne vous avez l'épicerie les
produits frais qui sont allés entre 0 et
-2 ça veut dire elle est ça tient
presque d'accord et à l'inverse vous
avez
sauter l'entretien l'hygiène les alcools
qui sont à -10 parce que c'est moins
essentiel alors je vous encourage à rien
évidemment mais vous pouvez arrêter de
vous brosser les dents par contre
arrêtez de manger c'est plus difficile
ou vous pouvez mettre un peu moins de
dentifrice sur la brosse à dents et ça
au final ça produit moins d'achat et
donc vous voyez c'est la différence
entre ce qui est essentiel manger c'est
essentiel et ce qu'il est moins voilà
alors il y a aussi plus de 7 personnes
sur 10 qui mangent moins de viande ou
moins de poissons ou ne mange plus rien
entre les repas c'est fou ça parce que
c'est cher quand vous avez 20%
d'inflation sur un produit qui vaut déjà
20 euros le kilo comme la viande de bœuf
20% sur 20 euros ça fait 4 euros quand
vous mettez 20 % sur du poulet qui est
moins cher ou des pâtes et qui sont
encore moins cher en proportion ça fait
pareil en proportion par contre en
valeur c'est pas pareil et donc voilà
pourquoi le poisson la viande et
notamment la viande de boucherie est en
train de décliner très fortement et puis
après vous avez aussi une petite part de
conviction personnelle on entend bien
aujourd'hui les antispécistes ce qui ce
qu'ils veulent moins manger de viande
mais c'est pas là l'explication
principale elle est vraiment clairement
sur des raisons financières
un gars qui avait prévu le crack le
néonome craque à l'époque qui a dit tous
les voyants sont au rouge économie
mondial pour que il se passe une énorme
catastrophe j'ai plein de gens qui me
disent fais attention aux banques etc
sorte ton argent de la banque mets-le
dans une banque plus sûr etc est-ce que
c'est vrai parce que c'est lui qui avait
prévu le craque le crack voilà
incroyable qui a eu 2008 et ça
exactement et donc il dit ça il dit que
tous les voyants sont au vert pour qu'il
y ait une énorme catastrophe économique
dans le monde entier donc et que les
banques même les banques peuvent être
touchées est-ce que c'est moi ma crainte
elle est plutôt sociale de manière assez
simple au début de la crise au début de
l'inflation il y a maintenant 18 mois et
consommateurs ont commencé par changer
d'endroit où il faisait leur course
quand vous avez peur de quelque chose
vous vous réfugiez c'est assez normal
ils se sont réfugiés vers les enseignes
qui étaient à leurs yeux les moins chers
ce que j'ai fait grosses voilà pour
protéger leur capacité d'achat ensuite
ça n'a pas suffi parce que l'inflation a
continué ils sont ils ont ils sont
descendus en gamme ils sont passés des
grandes marques aux un distributeurs ou
des marques de distributeurs au premier
prix c'est un phénomène de déclassement
par la qualité parce que ça leur
permettait de préserver la quantité de
ce qu'ils achetaient l'inflation a
encore continué et donc une partie des
Français sont obligés aujourd'hui dans
lever des articles de leur chariot ça
veut dire c'est un déclassement par la
quantité par les volumes et le problème
c'est que l'étape d'après ce mouvement
tel que je voulais décris c'est social
c'est une révolte alors je l'encourage à
rien évidemment j'analyse juste mais
c'est la parabole que j'appelle du pain
et du peuple quand il y en a un qui
manque à l'autre c'est jamais très bon
pour la cohésion sociale et voilà
pourquoi le gouvernement est aussi
inquiet que par moment on peut se dire
il faut un peu n'importe quoi parce que
il pilote à vue clairement parce que la
peur d'un mouvement gilet jaune ou gilet
rouge où je vois là peu importe elle est
partout dans le gouvernement parce que
c'est pour ça qu'il faut que ça tienne
là parce que si ça tient pas maintenant
avant que les prix baisses c'est très
inflammable on va vous donner les 10
conseils très rapidement pour faire vos
courses vous les avez donné on va vous
les rappeler privilégiez d'acheter les
articles en haut sont pas des rayons
parce que c'est les produits du milieu
les plus chers dans les supermarchés ce
que nous avait dit Olivier faire ses
courses le week-end juste avant la
fermeture le samedi en fin de journée
avant la fermeture du magasin le
dimanche midi avant la fermeture les
produits les plus chers sont plus
proches de la date de péremption donc
ils sont très souvent en réduction voilà
ça c'est des petits des petits conseils
essayez de payer ses courses en liquides
lorsqu'on est limité avec les billets on
n'achète pas d'articles en plus c'est
vrai que la carte on a l'impression
parfois de pas payer et après on se fait
on se fait défoncer derrière faire ses
courses le ventre plein voilà donc ça
aussi parce que en fait ça nous évite de
tout acheter c'est des petits conseils
comme ça qu'on vous donne toujours
regarder le prix au kilo regardez le pro
kilo souvent dans les grandes il y a des
il y a des grandes différences Olivier
ne prenez pas de caddie c'est ça plus
c'est grand plus on a envie de le
remplir ouais mais si vous avez trois
enfants à la maison le caddie est quand
même bien utile Cyril acheter les
marques des distributeurs
souvent 30 à 35% d'économie c'est
toujours le cas clairement clairement
moi je rajoute le sachet
regardez profiter les promotions le
prospectus on le décrit beaucoup alors
qu'il soit en version papier ou qui soit
sur ordinateur ou qui soit dans des
applications regardez toutes les promos
je vous prendre un exemple le weekend
dernier il y avait dans une grande
enseigne du filet de saumon à 12,99 bon
c'est un prix jamais vu voilà nations
enfin récemment jamais vu vous quand
vous voyez ça vous sautez dessus vous
aviez peut-être un envie d'acheter du
cabillaud maintenant vous n'achetez pas
de cabillaud vous achetez du saumon s'il
est à 12,99 et pour ceux qui manquent un
peu le truc vous avez vous avez plein
d'appels sur vos téléphones il y en a
c'est ce que j'appelle le tinder de la
promo en gros ça il y a ça s'appelle
bonial il y en a plusieurs je crois
qu'il y en a deux en fonction de
l'endroit où vous êtes et bien ils vont
vous il va vous présenter toutes les
promos autour de vous tous les bons
coups autour de vous c'est pour ça vous
voyez l'analogie bah du coup profitez-en
n'achetez que des produits en promotion
c'est quand même assez le bon sens et si
vous avez prévu de la cheville cabillaud
non vous achetez du saumon enfin le
weekend dernier il fallait acheter du
saumon d'accord pas du cabillaud ben
voilà et le week-end prochain ça sera
par exemple des sardines chez Carrefour
c'est 7,50 € les 3 kg voilà
ou sur la morue ça dépend ou sur la
morue voir le ton des fois alors voilà
faire sa liste de courses et s'y tenir
si vous n'avez pas de ligne vous achetez
n'importe quoi ça aussi c'est un
perruque oui et non oui non parce que
dans mon exemple si vous aviez marqué
cabillaud sur la liste que c'est le
saumon qui est en promotion bah vous
m'enlevez qu'à poissons
de fidélité ça ça risque pas de
t'arriver Guillaume non c'est vrai ou
des coupons qui peuvent voir plusieurs
il peut en avoir plusieurs le but c'est
d'en avoir une dans chaque magasin où il
va bah lui il en a plusieurs donc c'est
très bien aller au marché si vous faites
le marché toujours y aller à la
fermeture car les marchands bradent les
fruits et légumes qui leur reste ils
n'ont aucune envie de les ramener on est
d'accord il est bien sûr bien sûr c'est
c'est une règle d'or mais c'est comme
aller dans les bacs anti-gaspi des
grandes surfaces là pour le coup c'est
le matin qu'il faut y aller parce que
les grandes surfaces remplissent les
bacs anti gaspille le matin à
l'ouverture en fonction des produits qui
sont restés la veille au soir voyez donc
il arrive il va falloir y aller et à
l'ouverture et à la fermeture mais de
notre côté ça doit nous inciter quand
même à avoir en tête que bien consommé
oui ça prend du temps mais
accessoirement bien manger c'est pas un
petit sujet les amis manger c'est plus
important que tout dans notre vie parce
que c'est biologiquement indispensable
excellent merci
[Applaudissements]